Nobel Peace Prize Laureate Malala
yousafzai has made it her life's mission
to fight for women's educational rights
10 years ago she was on her way home
from school in Pakistan when a Taliban
gunman shot her in the head because she
was going to school she was just 15
years old at the time after her recovery
a very long recovery she created the
Malala fund to help other girls around
the world who want to learn first on CBS
mornings we're happy to say Malala
Youssef Sai joins us now from London
Malala it's good to see you I'm so glad
you are the perfect person to talk about
this I remember that terrible day when
you were shot the world was outraged
heartbroken and appalled Ten Years Later
can you believe and everybody thought
okay there will be change we were all
cheering for your recovery you devoted
your life to it ten years later we are
still fighting this fight does this
surprise even you
thank you um Gail for your time I am I'm
shocked uh and I'm devastated by the
news of banner University education for
Afghan women but I'm not shocked
um girls have been prohibited from
secondary schools for the last one and a
half years and we have been doing our
advocacy we are calling uh for a
response from world leaders that they
must take it seriously because we always
feared that it would get worse which is
happening right now it is getting worse
for women and this is two decades of
progress that women in Afghanistan
fought for it was their activism that
made it possible for them to get access
to education to get jobs to be part of
the parliament to be part of everyday
public life and suddenly that public
life is taken from them that that women
are erased from the public life
you know when the Taliban regained power
they said they were not going to
restrict the rights of women and the
Taliban minister is saying it's
necessary now because to prevent the
mixing of genders he says because some
of the subjects are being taught what
they're being taught violates the
principles of Islam what do you say to
that that logic that argument
there are a dozen of Muslim countries in
the world there is no ban on girls
education in those countries they do not
prohibit women from work so the logic
that the Taliban are applying here is is
actually not making any sense in Islam
there is actually uh verses that says
that Muslim men and women both should
seek knowledge the first word of the
Holy Quran is Iqra which means read and
uh I think I would you know I would say
that they go back and and re-read
everything and what they will realize is
that education is is part of the
religion as well
um so now it's it's patriarchy they're
failing in the cultural justification in
the religious justification as well
um and it's really about the future of
Afghan people and it's up to the Afghan
people to decide how they want to live
their life it's not a few groups of like
men to decide their futures for them
exactly right it's so hard to understand
how you can include half of a population
so is what is the answer here Malala for
True change is it Mass protest these
women are risking their lives when they
take to the streets
women in Afghanistan have not stopped
their fight for a single day they are on
their streets protesting for their right
to Freedom their right to education
their right to work and that is one
thing that is giving us some hope in
this moment but protests are happening
for their for their dignity in their
human rights and I hope that leaders
listen to their call soon it is taking
so long it has already been a year and a
half uh and and and and and the true
success of protests will be when our
leaders respond and hear their call to
action they defend their human rights
they make no compromise on the rights of
girls and women to education they ensure
that women have the right to work as
well
um so uh you know protests these calls
must be Amplified they must be heard
yes Malala yousafzai we thank you so
much for your time I know you recently
celebrated your one year anniversary so
congratulations your one year wedding
anniversary so we wish you and your
family a happy holiday and we'll talk
again thank you so much